[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: Thank you to Hannah.
HANNAH RICHARDS: Thank you.
So I just thought I'd
kick off with a little bit
from the book.
So the book goes through every
organ in your body one by one.
And obviously my favorite
organ is the gut.
And one of the things we,
maybe as humans but definitely
as British people, don't like
talking about, other than sex,
are the state of our bowels.
So.
"The gastrointestinal system is
a long and winding road housed
between the mouth and anus.
Chemical reactions take
care to break down the food
that you eat and the liquid
you drink into small particles
to be absorbed by
the bloodstream
and to be used by energy by you.
When ill health arises,
the gut is the first place
I look for answers.
Our gut takes on wear and tear
from the stresses of life,
and how we feel plays an
important part in how we eat.
And how we feel depends
largely on the amount of stress
that we have in our lives.
Eating is the most emotional
thing that we as humans do,
sometimes seven or
more times a day.
And the food we eat
or don't eat makes up
the health of your gut.
It is said that you
are what you eat,
and more recently, you
are what you don't absorb.
But I like to say a more
accurate description would be
you are what you don't excrete.
Flashback to the
Gillian McKeith days
when she was scraping around
in plastic boxes full of poo,
shouting at overweight mortified
souls who probably wished
they'd read the contract small
print before their poo became
household viewing.
Until Gillian
McKeith came along,
poo was a subject as taboo
as sex, especially in the UK.
And just as sex is certainly a
never easy subject to discuss,
your bowels and their
regularity take on much
of the same awkward tone.
To help me with my
clients, I have two charts.
One's called the
Bristol Stool Chart,
and the other is from
a book by Paul Chek
called "How to Eat,
Move and Be Healthy."
It gives names and faces to all
the potential states of bowels
and the consistency,
and they're all
dressed up in little outfits.
It's called the Poopie
Policemen lineup.
A lot of people do not know
what their bowels look like
or how often they go.
Being regular by
whose standards?
I remember a lady once
proudly telling me
of her regularity
of bowel movement.
It was only when
I asked her what
her regular was, that we
discovered she was chronically
constipated.
Twice a week is regular if
that's what you do every week,
but it's certainly not normal.
The bowel should move
roughly 30 centimeters--
12 inches-- of feces every day.
That's the optimum regularity
we should all be striving for.
So if you are moving your bowels
once or three times a day,
if you've been moving
your bowels less than this
and you've been told
it's normal, it isn't.
It's just very, very common."
And my name is Hannah Richards.
I'm the author of "The
Best Possible You."
It's a unique guide
to being able to heal
your body nutritionally.
So one of the things I
always ask people is,
have you got the
guts for good skin?
The skin is one of the-- is
the largest organ in your body,
and it's a really good mirror as
to what's going on inside you.
Inside you and with you and
for you, and all those things.
So when we talk
about the human body,
I'm talking about the physical,
the mental, the emotional,
and the physical.
And they all sing
and dance together.
You can't single one
thing out in the body.
Some types of medicine
try to do that,
but really, it's about looking
at all those different bodies
as a whole.
And as Adriana said, I work as
a nutritionist and lifestyle
coach on South Molton Street.
I used to run a health
clinic in Hampstead
called Move Three Sixty.
I founded a juice company
for medicinal juicing
which ran a range
of juices and shots
which were all for different
organs and systems.
And so I'm mainly in
Somerset now, and in London.
So today, I'm going to try and
be a little bit interactive
if you're all up for being
a bit of a health detective
with each other.
You certainly don't
have to at all.
You can opt out.
But the best thing about
being a nutritionist is really
is that it's just a bit of--
it's like being a detective.
I look at a person
and try and figure out
what's going on with them.
I do this by the way they
email me, the way they fill
in their paperwork, the
timings that they do that with,
the language they use,
what their skin looks like,
what their hair looks like, what
their fingernails look like.
I even get them to
stick their tongue out
to me because I can
tell a lot from organ
systems with the tongue.
And so it's really sort of
mapping all these things to be
able to find out what
is the etiology, what
is the root cause
of the ill health
that a person is experiencing.
It's worth just
saying at this point
that they're all
just little signs.
So if you have dark
circle under your eyes
and we say that's
the detoxification
system and the liver, you don't
have a chronic liver disorder.
It's just one pathway
in the right direction.
So the skin is a great
insight into your gut.
And the face gives us--
has anyone heard of face mapping
or done sort of acupuncture?
And so a lot of this is all
very Eastern medicine as well.
In Western medicine, we
tend to look through a hole
and see one thing and fix
that one thing without trying
to look at the reasons
as to why we got there
in the first place.
And so this is all about looking
at the signs and symptoms
before disease
rears its ugly head.
I'm sure we've all
got symptoms here.
I'm not going to ask you
to put your hands up,
but we collect them on
a daily, yearly basis.
And the problem
is, with symptoms,
is that they just fall into
this place of normality.
So we put up with them for
so long, they become normal.
Then we play the genetic card.
My mom has it.
My dad has it.
It's in the family.
It's part of us.
It's who we are.
And that's all very
true, but it's also quite
a nice, convenient excuse
not to take responsibility
for our own health.
So your tongue is--
again, it's going to show
you where all the organs are.
I'm going to show you
exactly the markings
and the colorations
of your tongue
so you can go and
have a look at it
and see how you could improve,
and whether those markings
match the symptoms that
you're experiencing, as well.
Hair is a great
one for absorption.
It's cool for men
to lose their hair.
It's not so cool for
women to lose their hair.
And yet, it's one of
the biggest things
I see in clinic more than--
probably after constipation
is hair thinning.
And that's got to do with
our digestive systems.
Our digestive capabilities
are so poor these days,
and that's because of stress.
And it's because of the bad
food choices that we have,
because the way the world has
made us into little robots,
and it's basically stress.
And stress, as we'll learn a bit
later, the biggest impact of it
is on our digestive system.
Nails.
Lucky for you if you've
got nail polish on.
If you haven't, we're going to
go through some nail things,
and we can look at
each other's nails.
So really easy things to look
at as well, look out for.
Bowels.
You know, if you don't look at
them, start looking at them.
They're the biggest
predictors of health.
They tell you so much about
what's going on in you.
Urine, and then
viscerosomatic pain patterns.
That's sort of like--
has anyone ever been to--
had an injury?
Of course.
And you go to the physio or the
osteopath, and you keep going,
and you don't really feel
like you're getting anywhere.
Well, when that
happens, what we need
to start doing is looking at
the nerve feeds to the organ.
So if your spine
is a long column,
all the nerves feed off the
vertebrae into your organs.
So when your right shoulder
hurts, for example,
and you can't--
no mechanical
therapy was working,
you need to start
looking at the liver,
whether it's sluggish,
whether it needs detoxing,
whether it's got fibrosis,
all these sorts of things.
So it's the organ systems that
need to start to be looked at.
The other thing to
say about the book,
as well, is that every organ
takes you through an emotion.
Again, in Chinese
traditional medicine,
we believe that every organ
is associated with an emotion.
So sometimes the reason that
initially there is a problem
can be an emotional issue
rather than anything else.
The liver, for example,
is anger and frustration.
And again, it's the one that
I work with most in clinic
because we're all stressed,
tired, and little addicts.
We're always sort of profiling
each other all the time
in your jobs.
You all work here because you're
really good at what you do.
And it's the same in
being a nutritionist.
I'm just looking at
people and going,
what is going on
with this person?
Why is their skin presenting
with a big red flush
on their cheeks?
Why does their face look like
it has this hue of tiredness?
And so you've just
looked at each other
and you've probably
spotted things.
And that's what I want
you to do to yourselves.
Start noticing what's
changing in you.
Because when things change,
they are signs and symptoms
of whether you're going
to go towards health
or whether you're going to move
towards a state of dis-ease.
Symptoms live next to the door
of disease and not health.
So the more symptoms
you start collecting
that you decide to call
normal, the further and longer
it takes to move
away and get better.
So that's just
worth remembering.
So, fingernails.
Has anyone had, like,
split fingernails?
This is a really easy one.
So sometimes your
fingernails get a bit brittle
and they break.
Now, for ladies, it can be
because we use nail polish.
I've got nail polish on.
Can't see mine.
It can be because we-- acetone
is such a horrible thing
to put on our nails,
so it breaks them
and makes them weak.
But if they do
break all the time,
it can be a sign that you're not
absorbing protein well enough.
So we might be eating
enough protein,
and we can eat all the best
organic food in the world,
but another question is
whether we absorb it.
And that's the
biggest relationship
with digestion and hormones.
We can eat all the best things,
but if we don't absorb it,
it almost doesn't
make any difference.
Lunars.
Anyone know what
your lunars are?
The lunars are like
the little half-moons.
So just look right at the
bottom of your nail beds.
You should have almost-- you
should have about eight lunars.
Sometimes people don't
have any lunars at all.
Sometimes it can be a
sign of B12 deficiency.
And again, that
can come and maybe
tie in with a brittle nail and
protein absorption as well.
Sometimes people have
longitudinal lines
along the nail bed.
This can be an iron deficiency,
a folic acid deficiency.
Sometimes you can
have fallen over,
had a trauma to the nail bed,
and then they never grow back.
So that's something
to consider as well.
Sometimes if you have a red
line by the top of the nail--
sort of on all of them where
it looks a little bit red--
that's a sign of a kidney
detoxification issue,
or certainly needs a bit of
help in those organs as well.
And then probably one
of the most common ones,
those little white
pittings on the nail.
Yeah?
And people, probably
growing up, everyone
was like, oh, it's calcium.
Didn't drink enough milk.
[LAUGHTER]
Because milk is the
only source of calcium.
It's actually a zinc deficiency.
And zinc is one of my favorite
supplements of all time.
It's responsible for so much.
Zinc is one of the cofactors for
making hydrochloric acid, which
lives in your stomach, which
helps you do everything,
basically, in your world.
And we see more acid reflux--
we'll probably get on to this
a bit later, but acid reflux--
anyone with indigestion is a--
it's because of a deficiency
in hydrochloric acid.
Adult-onset acne, for example,
is a deficiency in zinc.
So zinc only likes to
be uptaken by itself.
So if you're thinking
about getting some zinc
or you have zinc, you should
take it last thing at night,
not with anything else.
If you feel sick whenever taking
a supplement, or especially
zinc, because
sometimes you can, then
it's a sign that your
digestive capabilities,
the enzymes are quite low,
so you can't break it down.
If you can't break
down food, you
can't break down a supplement.
So you can take a
whole load of things,
but again, if you don't
have the enzymes or the bile
or the acids to break
things down, then again,
it's a little bit pointless.
So obviously, healthy
nails, you should
be able to hold them down
and the blood disappears
and it pops back up.
And if that happens,
that's great.
If not-- another little trick,
if you're dehydrated, maybe
on a Friday morning, you
can pick your skin up
and it should hold.
If there's enough water in you,
it should hold a little bit.
So you should be able to see
the skin fall, as opposed
to completely disappear.
So if it disappears without
you being able to see it,
drink some more water.
So I'm just going to give
you a bit of a warning
about the next slide.
So these are-- so this is
the longitudinal one, which
is maybe sometimes
the iron deficiency.
And sometimes nails
also quite give you
big signs about cardiovascular.
Like some of these nails
look very white and a pale.
You know, the blood isn't
pumping around the body enough.
And at the surface of the
skin are all the capillaries.
So we should always
see this redness.
Which is why, if you
do the nail test,
you should be able to
see a lot of redness.
It disappears and then
pops back up again.
That's the pitting, which
is the zinc deficiency.
This is the brittle nails.
So if you have got this, it
could be a protein deficient--
malabsorption, then
things like taking
in proteins in a more digestible
form, like chicken soup,
like bone broth, like
collagen, all these things--
it's almost like someone's
done the chewing for you.
So it's less stress on the body.
You're just going
to take it all in.
Now, the toe.
This is like a systemic
fungal infection.
And often you see this in people
with Alzheimer's and dementia,
where the body is just
constantly breaking down.
Sometimes the beginning
of a fungal infection
can present with maybe a
black spot on a toenail.
It's normally always the
toenails and not the fingers.
But this is when the--
whether the fungal infection,
which is a yeast overgrowth,
has really gotten out of hand.
So sometimes we might see a
yeast overgrowth on a tongue.
You might see it vaginally.
You might see-- feel it,
like in the nasal area.
Basically, every orifice
we have, if it's inflamed,
the body's inflamed and unhappy,
it will try and excrete.
It wants to get stuff out.
And it does that by getting rid
of mucus and things like that.
So all these, also, like the
flakiness around the cuticle,
these are deficiencies in
things like essential fatty
acids, your omegas that
you get from your fish
and your avocados, and
all these things as well.
So everything is giving
you an indication
that not all is well.
And the longer you
put up with stuff--
you know, there's that saying,
the longer you put off health,
you're going to have to find
time later to make it up.
So it's really
worthwhile looking out
for these signs and symptoms,
because they're really
easy to fix.
I think with people
with adult-onset acne,
zinc is a really easy way
to improve that, for sure,
because it's the start
of the digestive process.
So yeah.
I mean, anything gut-related,
within two to four weeks
if you do it all
sort of 95%, you're
going to see differences
because of the cell turnover.
It's only when people commit
to things like 60% or 70%,
then results don't really show.
OK.
So face mapping.
Apologies if you--
can you see that?
I'll point through it.
So we probably all know
that when we've gone out
and had a bit too much to drink,
we wake up in the morning,
we've got bloodshot eyes.
Certainly if you've
got Caucasian skin,
it is a thankless--
it shows everything, you know?
That no amount of
makeup is going
to cover up a big night out.
And mainly we see it
right under the eyes here.
And they either-- they're very
black, they're sort of purple.
You can see all
the tones in them.
And that is because you've
overloaded the detoxification
system and the
kidneys and the liver
are under a bit of stress.
You'll also notice that when
you're on a really nice health
cleanse and you're
feeling really good,
that you don't have those
dark circles under your eyes.
Now, if you always have the
dark circles under your eyes,
then that's definitely one
of those sort of markers
to go, oh, maybe I need to look
at my kidney, my gallbladder,
my liver, the detoxification
system, because maybe it's
not functioning as
well as it could.
In the book,
there's a case study
on the kidneys with a
friend I got to know,
and I always thought that he
just didn't look very well.
And it was only later
that we discovered-- well,
he told me because he only
discovered it late in life--
that he only had one kidney.
And he only found out
when he was sort of 44.
I have another friend who
has like four kidneys.
So sometimes you just
don't know what's
going on if you don't ask
the questions or investigate
or are aware of your
signs and symptoms.
Down here is another
place of kidneys.
I actually probably see
it more in men than women,
like sometimes a bit
of cracking here.
Hormonally for women under
the chin-- and for men,
but obviously women will see it
through the cycle, the changes.
Sort of spots or
things around here.
If you have any sort
of pussy sort of spots,
then that's your
lymphatic system.
It's got too much
toxicity in it.
And your lymph system
is like a system
all over the body that's
designed to drive toxicity out.
You know, like the motility
of the peristalsis.
Red cheeks.
Sometimes they call it the
butterfly effect or rosacea.
But for me, it's low
hydrochloric acid.
So the acid lives
in your stomach.
It breaks down protein.
And when you struggle with--
let's say you had acid reflux,
for example, or indigestion,
that would be a sign
that your acid was low.
If the acid is low
in the stomach,
then you have got more chance of
picking up pathogens, antigens
crossing over into
the bloodstream
because it hasn't been
washed by the acid.
It's a bit like
the theory of why
we have to wash before we go
into a public swimming pool
full of chlorine.
But it's the same thing.
If there's no acid
in your stomach,
then nothing gets washed.
It's the first line of defense.
So if you suddenly
feel like maybe you
can't eat meat as
well as you used to,
or fat makes you feel
a little bit sick,
these could all be
signs that you've
got a low hydrochloric acid.
Or equally, if you do have acid
reflux or indigestion, again,
that's low hydrochloric acid.
Now, some of you
may be thinking,
she's got that completely
the wrong way around,
because the medical industry
think that that is true.
And so what they do is
give you Rennie tablets
to dampen down a level of
acid that you don't already
have, thereby depleting the
acid levels that you have,
thereby not giving
you a line of defense.
So if you have any questions
about that, let me know.
But it's a-- and
Rennies are never
going to solve the problem.
They are a plaster
to not really getting
to the etiology of why we have
acid reflux in the first place.
The other reason it could
be because it's a bacteria
called Helicobacter pylori,
which will, again, only exists,
only can survive if there
is no acid in the stomach.
Otherwise the acid
would kill it.
So if I took some acid
out of your stomach,
it would burn a
hole in your jeans.
I mean, it's that potent.
So if your stomach is
an alkaline environment,
it's not going to be
breaking down any food.
That's why we feel
full, we feel bloated,
we create fermentation.
We get SIBO.
And you can see how it's
just a knock-on effect.
Sometimes here,
they call the lines
down here sort of the liver,
angry lines, alcohol--
maybe an addiction to alcohol.
The nose, we say is the--
when it sort of flares
up red is the pancreas,
the sweetness of life,
blood handling issues
are always looked at there.
So there's lots of
reasons and there's
lots of signs and
symptoms on your face.
And it's good to be always
looking at those changes
as well.
On the skin, anyone ever
got light little pimply bits
on their arms?
That's something called
keratosis pilaris.
Sometimes you can get it
on the back of your legs.
It's essential fatty
acid deficiency.
Really easy to get rid of, or--
well, I say easy.
The thing is with
supplements is you've got
to force a change in the body.
So if you're taking one omega-3
every day, or one probiotic,
you're not really going to
change the status in what's
going on in your body.
And that's why, if you're
not testing for things, then
we're just guessing
with a dosage
that someone somewhere
has recommended to take.
We really want to get everything
we-- all our nutrients
in through our food.
But keratosis pilaris, you'd
need a really high amount
of omega-3s, essential fatty
acids, to shift that condition.
OK, so here we go to the tongue.
So I'll just do the
digestive system mainly.
So when you stick your tongue
out, A, you want it to hold.
Some people's tongues shake.
That's a magnesium deficiency.
It's stress.
We have this autonomic
nervous system--
has anyone heard of that?
A little bit.
On one side, you have the
sympathetic nervous system.
The other side, you have the
parasympathetic nervous system.
For example, the
digestive system
has to be parasympathetic
to not be constipated,
to move freely
through the intestines
out through the colon.
So all the stressed
people you know,
they're probably constipated.
All the happy-go-lucky,
yeah, let's-- no problem.
They're never going
to be constipated.
They're like, hold on,
I just need the loo.
Whereas the stressed
people, you know,
they're living in the
sympathetic zone all the time.
Everything's tight.
Everything's shortened.
And so it's just
a knock-on effect.
The breathing changes.
The posture changes.
The musculoskeletal
system changes.
They're-- you know.
And so there are
signs and symptoms
and organs and diseases that
live on the sympathetic side,
and others that live on
the parasympathetic side.
So the digestive system.
Right down the middle
of your tongue,
if there are any
cracks in it, then this
is definitely looking at
a digestive issue here.
Sometimes, then, you'll have
these little fissures that
come off that big
ridge in the middle,
and you might have
gas, bloating, colitis.
Colitis is a condition I
see more than anything.
And it's really
an emotional issue
that comes from high
levels of stress.
Colitis can-- presents
in the large intestines,
whereas Crohn's presents
in the whole gastro tract.
And all that is happening is
that nothing is being absorbed,
so people find themselves going
to the bathroom up to 20 times
a day.
So if they're always excreting,
then they're not hanging--
they're not taking in
any vitamins, minerals,
any nutrition.
So they're always drained.
They're always tired.
And then that has a knock-on
effect to the emotional status
of anxiety--
not wanting to eat, not
wanting to go out, because you
have this chronic bowel issue.
So the other really
obvious one, I guess,
would be a white tongue.
Obviously, you can eat foods
and see different colors,
but a white tongue,
again, that would
be looking at potentially
a yeast infection.
Sometimes it can change the
times of the month as well.
So right down at the front,
the tip of the tongue,
you've got the heart.
Either side are the
left and the right lung.
Right in the middle
is the stomach,
so that's why you mainly see
the fissures splitting off
and the longitudinal
ridge down the middle.
And that's because
so many people
have issues with
hydrochloric acid production.
And then the intestines
at the back as well.
So, what a good thing to do
is, stick your tongue out
when you get home,
take a picture of it.
And if you're going to change
your nutrition or some things
in life, then
that's a good marker
of how things have changed.
So this is a nice,
healthy tongue.
It doesn't have that
longitudinal ridge right
down the middle.
It's not scalloped
down the side.
Sometimes you can see
these sort of teeth marks
in the side of people's tongues.
This is a beefy tongue,
which is a B12 deficiency.
Like sometimes people's
tongues are a bit too big
for their mouths.
That's a big beefy tongue.
This is-- the papillae in this
one is a bacterial infection.
So when the papillae
open, when the fissures
have been open for too long,
then it collects bacteria
and it looks like it's
a bit black like that.
And so you're constantly
carrying around toxicity.
It's like people who smoke
and chew gum at the same time.
You know, it's like the
quickest way to have a problem.
This is-- I always
call-- this is called
a geographical
tongue, but I like
to see it as-- you know when
you cut open a red cabbage?
Looks a bit like
that, doesn't it?
So this is like a huge,
long-time metabolic syndrome.
So there are lots of
issues going on there.
You don't see it a lot,
but you definitely see it.
So tongue health is
really important.
Chinese traditional
medicine swears by it
and they live by it
and they are constantly
checking tongue health.
And then we've got the
referred pain patterns.
In the book there's
a chart to tell you
which organs belong to which
parts of the vertebrae.
So if you do have an
injury or a chronic pain
and you haven't
been able to fix it,
it's definitely time to
look at your organ system.
Just checking the time.
OK.
So I'm going to
really quickly go
through one organ with you all.
And I picked the
liver because it's
the grandfather of all organs.
And we're all such
workaholics these days,
and we probably do things
to excess, I'm guessing.
So I thought I'd go
through the liver
and tell you what
the job of it is.
So the liver is a little
bit like a Hoover.
Who here Hoovers?
All you men.
And when your Hoover bag
gets full, what do you do?
Empty it.
Absolutely.
Because it can't pick up the
dirt on the floor anymore.
Now, if you think of your
liver a bit like a Hoover,
when it gets full,
what do we do?
Carry on.
Because we're not listening
to the signs and the symptoms.
So when those dark
circles don't go,
when your back,
upper back hurts,
when your urine is
constantly dark,
when you feel a bit
knocky more than usual,
you have a bit of anger,
frustration, all these things
going on, you're sort
reaching for the biscuit more
than the fruit,
these are all signs
that the liver is a
little bit overloaded
and needs filtering out.
Now, green juice will help, but
it's definitely not a detox.
Because if the liver isn't
working, what happens
is a re-hepatic circulation.
So it's what I call ghetto gut.
You do a cleanse for two weeks,
but because no filtration
is happening, you're just
circulating the toxins back
from the digestive
system to the liver
and back, and
they're not leaving.
Does that makes sense?
So if you feel like
you can't lose weight,
if you feel like you're
fat, fed up, and fatigued,
or any one of those, and you've
looked at lots of things.
The gym stopped working,
the salmon and green lettuce
isn't working either.
You know, getting into bed, not
going out with your friends,
you feel like you're in a
bit of a conundrum, it's time
to look at your liver because
it just gets a bit sluggish.
And like everyone in
life, when we're sluggish,
we don't really
perform very well.
And those are all the things
you might start seeing.
Again, in the book, every organ
gives you this kind of chart.
So the liver is a yin
organ, it's a female organ.
If you know about chakras,
then the main sort
of purpose of the liver is
personal power and self will,
which is why I often
see with people
the anger and frustration comes
out in its addictive nature.
So you can be
addicted to anything.
You can be addicted to alcohol,
you can be addicted to health.
But that normally
comes out in the liver.
So those are just, in
the book, all the organs
have that meridian chart.
There you go.
Henry the Hoover.
So, how do you start
fixing your liver,
or how do you help it along?
All your green foods
are the best things.
They're full of magnesium.
If you're tired and
stressed, magnesium
is one of the best
supplements you can take.
Obviously, internally it's
going to help the bowels move.
It creates diarrhea,
if you like.
If you overdose with magnesium,
expect to see some diarrhea.
Everyone's dosage is different
so you just have to titrate,
which means take one tablet
one day, the next day up,
regulate to two, and so on until
you get the desired effect.
If you start taking
supplements all at once,
you'll have no idea what
works and what doesn't.
So always take
them one at a time.
So all your green foods,
it's worth saying as well,
that without green
vegetables and everything--
we're also into raw these
days, raw and vegan,
and that's great.
But if you have a
digestive issue,
your body does not want
to break down raw food.
It wants it steamed.
It wants it cooked
because it's easier
for the digestive system.
So if you blow after a
salad, stop eating salads
and go to steamed vegetables.
I work in Cairo at
a place over there,
and everyone is bloated
and constipated.
It's because when they eat well,
they eat salad and chicken,
and when they don't, they're
doing everything else.
So when I take them off
the salad and the raw food,
their digestive
capabilities get better
and their bloating comes down.
Bloating is just a symptom
of the gut being weak.
Food intolerances.
The major five intolerances are
cow's milk, egg, nut, wheat,
and gluten.
And so these are the
things we eat more--
all the time.
I grew up on cereal,
which is basically
wheat, gluten, and milk, so
there's three straightaway.
So the more you
eat of something,
the more you wear down
the digestive enzymes that
get to break down that food.
And then you end
up with a bloating.
If I took out your gut and
I laid it on the floor,
it would cover half
a tennis court.
And the whole gut is
covered in microvilli.
And at the top of the villi are
villi and they excrete enzymes.
So if you overdo
milk your whole life,
then you wear out the enzymes
that break down the milk.
And then when you put
milk back into the gut,
it bloats out because the
gut is almost like bald.
It's like a bald head.
There's no means to
break the food down
into smaller particles
to cross over and be
absorbed and digested.
So food intolerance,
when you feel
like you bloat, and you can't
pinpoint what you bloat at,
and you now feel like
it's just everything,
that's when we need to start
repairing the permeability
of the gut lining.
So if you bloat with a
certain food, it's easy.
Take it out.
But if it feels like suddenly
it becomes everything
you're bloating
at, then you need
to start fixing the
inside of the lining.
So sometimes the
liver is all about--
it's about anger and jealousy.
Obviously we see
lots of addictions.
Depression as well, which
is linked to the bacteria
in the microbiome,
which is a huge subject.
But one thing I would
say quickly about probi--
bacteria, if you eat a
really good varied diet,
you don't really need them.
If you are taking them and
you're taking one a day,
it's a bit of a waste of time.
You need to make sure
they're multi-strained,
and every three months
you change your probiotic.
You know, your microbiome is
full of bacteria-- billions,
trillions.
So if you're just putting
one lactobacillus in,
it's hard work.
So you need to be putting
a multitude of bacteria
back in the gut.
And why not do that with food?
Why not do that with kefir,
with kombucha, with sauerkraut,
with kimchi, with fermented
things with soy, rather than
very expensive probiotics?
If you've been on antibiotics
or you've had trauma,
then absolutely there's
a need for them.
But if you are a healthy
looking person, which you all
look like to me, and you are
spending money on probiotics
and they're not
really doing anything,
then they're probably not.
Here are some supplements
for your liver.
One of my favorite is B6.
If women, for example, get
tender breasts the week
before their period, that's
definitely a deficiency in B6.
B6 is like the
little cofactor guy
that makes everything
in the body work.
So you can't go wrong
by taking a bit of B6.
NAC-- N-acetyl cysteine--
is a really potent antioxidant.
It's a precursor
of a glutathione.
If you were to take any
of these before you drank,
and the day after, you
would repair your hangover
quite well because it helps--
everyone's going-- because it
helps do the detoxification.
It's always best to take
herbs naturally as opposed
to in a supplementation form.
But NAC or glutathione
is exponentially
one of the best
things you can take.
You can get glutathione
in a shot form
and have it injected into the
muscle, and it completely--
you know, if you're
in drug rehab therapy,
you'd be on shots
of NAC all the time.
And glutathione-- it's
just more expensive.
Magnesium.
If you're stressed, it's
the biggest supplement
for your heart, especially men.
So if you feel like you're
always running uphill
against the tide, then
make sure you've got
some magnesium in your life.
If you're chronically
constipated
and you drink enough water and
you eat your steamed greens,
take some magnesium.
If you don't eat enough
greens and drink water,
then do that first.
So here's a big tip if you
have got digestive issues.
Always eat at the
same time every day.
Your body's a bit like a baby.
When a baby cries,
what does it need?
He either needs some love,
needs some food, or needs a poo.
And we are no different.
And what we do all the time is
we keep our bodies guessing.
We wake up in the morning,
we go straight to hit.
We don't give it any water,
we don't give it any food.
We keep it up till 2:00 AM.
We wake up at 6:00,
we go to work.
You know, the amount of
clients I see who go,
god, I haven't got
any water today,
and they're fishing around
in the room for water.
We've got to look
after our bodies
if we want them to work for us.
And the signs and the
symptoms are the easiest way
that you can do this.
Our health is our
responsibility.
Yeah, there are genetic,
chronic, life-defying diseases
that we get in the world.
But most of the
time, it's up to us.
And if you're looking
at all the things
that we've been through today,
if you're aware when things
don't work or do work, if you're
aware of your emotional status
and your physicality
and how you eat,
then you'll probably be OK.
And if you're not, then you've
got some tools in your toolbox
now to start being even more
optimum than you probably are.
So my challenge to you
all is, spend tomorrow--
I know you all eat
here, so it's not really
a challenge for you guys.
At the weekend.
Here we go, at the weekend--
you can't eat anything that's
been packaged, wrapped,
or sold in plastic.
Sounds easy.
But report back.
And that means it's the
easiest thing to do,
because then we have
to prepare our food.
And I'm just going
to do one last thing.
So if you could
open them that way.
And what I want you both
to do is just open them
and smell them.
And then pass them around.
Everyone smell these crisps.
AUDIENCE: We don't eat these.
HANNAH RICHARDS: You can.
You can.
They're Burts.
They're quite good crisps.
So is anyone feeling like
they've got more saliva
going around in their mouth?
So, what you've just created
is the most essential thing
you need to create
for digestion,
and it's called the
cephalic response.
If you don't create
the cephalic response,
then you do not
create the enzymes
that are required to
break the food down.
And because we're
all on our computers
and we're always
working from our desk,
we don't create the
cephalic response,
and that is the major reason
why people find their way to me.
And so sometimes I say,
are you a fast eater?
And they go, yeah, yeah,
no, I'm really fast.
And I'm like, well, come
back when you slow down.
Because it's the only thing
people need to do, is chew.
If you don't prepare yourself,
it's like anything in life.
If you don't prepare, then you
don't get the desired effects.
So the cephalic response
is the start and end
of optimum digestion.
And it gets created when
we smell vinegar and salt.
So, some top tips.
10 minutes before
you eat, obviously
think about what
you want to eat.
Also, we have to get off
these machines to eat.
You know, the body is in this
hierarchical state of survival.
And more energy gets
diverted to our eyes,
because it's the-- our eyes are
always looking out for safety.
And so when you're
eating, reading a report,
more energy is going
to the optical nerves
than it is to your
digestive system.
So you're not going
to digest very well.
So the easiest
thing, and I don't
understand why human beings
can't do it, is have a break!
Take an hour off for
lunch, or half an hour,
and sit down and enjoy the
food with your friends.
If you've got digestive
issues and you do that,
you probably won't have them.
So create the cephalic
response, turn your phone off,
and enjoy food.
Because by all means, we're all
eating it a lot during the day,
aren't we?
You know, we're like--
we're little guzzlers
who are always looking.
And here, there's food
everywhere, right?
There's food everywhere.
I mean, you guys are eating
whether you're hungry or not.
So we need to make sure that
we're hungry for the food,
and you do that by
creating mealtimes.
So anyway, I hope
you found it useful,
and if you've got
any questions here,
I'm more than happy
to answer them.
I know some people have to go.
I'm going to be around for next
half an hour, so fire away.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: So, thank
you very much.
A really great talk.
Really enjoyed all of that.
My question was, you
spoke a lot about food.
I know you're
probably going to say
it's bad, but just interested
to get your thoughts on caffeine
and caffeine levels
that are suitable.
HANNAH RICHARDS: Yeah.
You know, good question.
I love coffee.
It's the question of
why you need coffee.
So if you wake up in
the morning and you go,
oh, I can't wait
for coffee, then
you might have a bit of
an energy issue there.
If you drink instant
coffee, you're
going to rip your gut up in one
fell smoo-- and really easily.
So instant coffee
is one of the worst
things you can do for your gut.
If you have coffee after you
eat-- water, food, and then
coffee, that's my general rule.
Never have coffee between
the hours of 11:00 and 1:00,
because it's the
hours of the heart,
and the heart is all about
hate and love and shock.
And just as much as we can--
the heart can get shocked
through a good thing
and a bad thing, you don't
really want those hours to be.
That's why it's lunchtime.
Yeah, and that's why we want
to be sat down, relaxed,
in a relaxed state.
And coffee perks you up and
send shocks around the body.
So if you're hydrated
enough, drink it.
But drink it away from food.
And if you've got more than two
a day, three a day, you know,
you're masking something.
So.
But yeah, it's essentially--
if you drink coffee and
you get heart palpitations,
then put some fat in it.
Like put some coconut oil
in it, some butter in it,
you know, good milk in it.
That's the fat that makes
the energy go for longer.
AUDIENCE: Thanks so much.
Really interesting.
I was just curious if
you could talk anything
about the Ayurvedic system.
You'd mentioned, you
know, steaming vegetables
versus eating them raw.
And I was just
curious if you see
that kind of in the practice, or
if you think it's a good idea,
or kind of people should
steer away from it?
HANNAH RICHARDS: Yeah,
and a good question.
So, Ayurveda is like an old
Indian-wisdom traditional
system of nutrition and yoga,
essentially, and a way of life.
They call the agni--
the agni is your
digestive system,
so it's always about lighting
the fire in the body.
If your agni is
strong, then you'll
be able to break down foods.
So I always see the
digestive system a little bit
like a fire.
If you don't know how your
body works-- like in Ayurveda,
there's three doshas--
Kapha, Pitta, Vata.
And it's all about
whether you're
putting in cooling
foods or warming foods,
but foods that stimulate
that digestive fire.
So if you're always
putting in paper to a fire,
what essentially
happens to the fire?
It goes out.
So if you're always putting
Haribos into your body
because you constantly
need energy,
you'll always be
crashing and burning.
If you put wood into that
fire, it burns for a long time,
you can get on with your
day, and it's sustainable.
And that's about Ayurveda,
finding the right mix
of foods or metabolic typing.
Once you've found your
own individual makeup,
then you understand
how to feed your body
to keep the acne, the fire, in.
I follow it a lot, yeah.
AUDIENCE: I guess in the
back of her question,
would you recommend
one versus the other,
or is it all personal?
Should I have steamed or raw,
or is it a rule of thumb?
HANNAH RICHARDS:
Yeah, it's very much--
when I first got
into nutrition, I
found it pretty
illogical and a bit green
farmerish, how, I have bad skin.
OK, take this
pharmaceutical drug.
I have bad skin,
take some vitamin E.
And so I found a
type of nutrition
called metabolic
typing, which basically
says that we're all different.
So you can be a fast
oxidizer, slow oxidizer,
or mixed oxidizer,
and some people burn--
if you go back to your biology
lessons at school and you go
back to the Krebs cycle,
beta oxidation, all that--
yeah, you've all wiped
it out, I can see.
It's all about how we burn
different fuels for energy.
I burn fat and protein
quite sustainably.
Carbohydrates I
burn really quickly.
Some people use-- so I
don't use them very well.
You might use
carbohydrates really well.
And so once you find
your mix, then you're
feeling more optimal
all the time.
So it is very individual.
But essentially, if you're
a fully functional--
if you have a fully
functional gut,
you should be able to
take-- eat anything.
You know, we're not
designed to be gluten-free.
It's because our guts are
a bit mucked up these days,
that we're all now--
got, you know,
[INAUDIBLE] over us,
that we've all got
these conditions, that
have may just gone a bit crazy.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned about
keeping ourselves hydrated
and that's good for
our digestive systems.
So do you have any
recommendations
about the temperature
of the water?
HANNAH RICHARDS: Yeah.
So, water should always be room
temperature because the sta--
anything like really ice-cold,
certainly in Ayurveda,
but the stomach doesn't want--
Chinese traditional
medicine, cold water
is just a shock to the body.
Like, it's OK outside.
I do a lot of
cold-water swimming,
swim in Hampstead
Heath, and that--
because that stimulates
your vagus nerve.
And the vagus nerve is
the 10th cranial nerve
that is responsible for
the digestion in your body.
But when the water's
going into you,
then it's too much of a shock
and a sympathetic response,
a stress release to the body.
So room temperature
all the time.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
HANNAH RICHARDS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much
for the inspirational talk.
And my question
is on superfoods.
They are super popular nowadays.
How much do you recommend them?
How much should we
take on a daily basis?
And how much should we
avoid them, if at all?
HANNAH RICHARDS: Sure.
I always think that, I don't
know, a group of journalists
would sit around a
table, or PR people,
and they'd be like, what should
we call a superfood today?
Shall it be kiwis?
Shall it be apples?
I mean, they have this sort of
hierarchical status when they
shouldn't.
All food is fairly equal
when it's seasonal,
when it's organic, when it's
from the country of origin.
So superfoods, for me,
a bit of a phenomenon
that I don't really understand.
And a bit-- the press have
made them to be gimmicky.
So blueberries are a superfood.
Why is blueberry a superfood
and not a strawberry?
You know?
I think that's the point.
And if I've answered your
question well enough,
I think if you're
eating seasonally,
then you're doing
a really good job.
And therefore, everything
is superfood in that season.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: Cool.
HANNAH RICHARDS: Well done.
SPEAKER 1: Well,
thank you, Hannah.
And if you have questions
to her individually,
if you don't want
to talk out loud,
I'm sure she'd be open to--
HANNAH RICHARDS: Yeah.
I've got some cards and
some little book things
there, but absolutely.
If you have any questions
about your bowels
and you want to private
email me, I'm very--
I'm all ears.
[APPLAUSE]